Arozabillahi minas Shaytan regime Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim Allahumma Salliya Allah Saidana Muhammadin Wa Ala Ali Saidana Muhammadin Wabaraku Sallam Rabbish Rahli Sadri Wa Yasidli Amri Wahlul Rukdatam illisani yaf kahu kawli Assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu We're studying Surah Al-Fateha and we've completed
the first four verses Bismillah Rahman Raheem Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen Ar Rahman Raheem Maliki Aumit Deen uh so now in this session we're going to look at Ihdina Saraatul Mustaqim this verse is commonly translated as guide us to the straight path right Ihdina Saraatul Mustaqim guide us to the straight path now
let's look at what does that mean normally we think about it like you know so when I say to you guide me to your house what am I asking for I'm asking for instructions right directions that's what guidance essentially means it means instructions or directions now how are you going to give me these instructions what are the different ways
in which you can give me instructions or directions.
So for instance, you can say, take this particular road and go three miles on it and then turn left, right?
That is how typically you will give instructions for a particular destination.
You'll just list it out for the person.
Another way you can do that, you can tell me, you can guide me by saying, you know what, just stand at this bus stop,
and take this particular bus and then get off at this particular stop.
So that's another way you can guide me.
This is guidance through the bus, right?
It is guidance through a medium or through an intermediary.
So what you're saying in the second mode of instructions is that you don't have to do anything.
The bus will do all the work for you.
You're telling me that all you have to do is make sure that you're at the right bus stop at the right time and you catch the right bus and then let just let the bus get you to your destination.
That's the second way of giving instructions through an intermediary or through a medium.
The third way is that you can say, look, I'm headed home right now.
Why don't you just jump in the car with me and I'll take you all the way, right?
Those are the three ways by which you can guide me or direct me to your house.
First is through a set of instructions.
Second is through a medium or an intermediary.
And the third is by literally taking me to that destination yourself.
It's very important that you understand these three, the differences between these three modes of instructions.
Now, what is so cool about this verse, and listen to this carefully, is that asking for guidance through a set of instructions or through a set of directions in Arabic, it is called Ihidina ilaa seraat al-mustaqim.
Ihidina ilaa seraat al-mustaqim.
Guide me through a set of instructions.
Asking for guidance using a medium would be Ihdina bis seraat al-mustaqim.
The letter ba would be included with seraat.
Ihdina bis seraat al-mustaqim.
Asking for completely assisted guidance, which is the third form in which you are literally holding my hand and taking me to the destination, that would be Ihdina ala seraat al-mustaqim.
You see?
Now what's interesting about the Fateha is that we are not asking Allah for instructions by saying, Ihdina ila siraat al-mustaqim.
We're not asking Him for instructions by saying, Ihdina bissiraat al-mustaqim.
And we're not saying, Ihdina ala siraat al-mustaqim.
We are not using any of those words.
we are just simply saying .
You see that?
We're omitting the ila, we're omitting the ba and we're omitting the ala in our request for our instructions.
Now why is that relevant?
Because according to the rules of Arabic linguistics, when you don't use any of these words, what you actually mean is all of them at the same time.
you see the principle of Arabic is that if you are using none of these words you're linguistically using all of them otherwise you would have to use these separate sentences so now when we say what we're really saying is direct me to the straight path through your instructions which is the Quran
We're saying guide me to the straight path through your intermediaries, through the mediums, through the example of people like Rasulullah , Malana Ali , the Aima, the Dua, and then finally hold my hand and walk me along this path until I reach my destination.
Grant me your constant companionship as I walk along this path.
Subhanallah.
It's amazing.
See, a school counselor gives us guidance, guides the students, right?
That's the job of a school counselor.
His guidance is basically information, right?
A traffic officer's guidance is information.
The GPS guiding you in your car is information, but Allah's guidance is more than just information.
Because Allah's guidance has to do with the personal choices that we have to make every single moment.
So we're not just asking for directions, we're also asking Him for the strength and His assistance in helping us make those right decisions.
These are two very different things.
Because sometimes we can have all the right information and we can still make the wrong decisions.
Also, if you think about it, you know, guidance, what did we say guidance is?
It's just a set of instructions, right?
How many times do we need information?
One time.
You know, if I've been given the right information, I don't have to ask for it again.
once I know the direction to your house that's it I'm not going to keep asking you again and again but how many times do we ask Allah for guidance over and over again as a standard right it's like drinking water you cannot say I drank water yesterday so I'm not never going to need it again it doesn't work that way if you want to survive you have to drink again and again every single day
So just as our bodies become thirsty for water and food, our heart keeps starving for guidance.
This is why we keep coming back to Allah in every single prayer with this request of 'Ihdina suraatul mustaqeen'.
Now let's look at this word 'Ihdina'.
So guidance we already talked about.
But what's really interesting is that if you look at the root word for ehdina, it comes from huda.
So in this context, the derivative is hidaya, which means guidance, which I just explained to you.
But what's interesting is that huda is also the root word for hadiya.
Now what does hadiya mean?
It's also used in Urdu.
The word Hadiya, it means a gift.
Now for an Arab living in the desert when he's lost, right?
Think about an Arab who lives in the desert and he got lost in the desert.
What is the greatest gift that you can give him?
Even more than water.
Because water is not going to be good enough.
It will last him maybe one more day.
Food is maybe going to last him a couple more days.
So from an Arab's perspective, especially an Arab who is lost in the desert, what is the greatest of all gift for him?
Guidance, directions back to his home, back to his family.
That's the ultimate gift.
So we're asking Allah not just for any gift, we're asking Allah for the ultimate gift.
because Allah's guidance is the ultimate gift for a believer.
So it becomes so much more than just instructions or informations, you see?
It completely changes the perspective of a believer from just simply a set of rules.
It creates the sense of gratitude because instructions and directions are now perceived as a gift.
a gesture of love, a gesture of care.
That's when you give a gift to somebody, right?
You don't give a gift to somebody you hate.
You always give a gift to somebody you love.
So now these instructions and this set of information of how to live our life, it no longer feels like this burden that we have to bear, but rather it feels like a gift.
That is the perspective
that changes when you understand the linguistics of the word hidaya or huda now let's look at sirat what is sirat?
so it is generally translated as a path right but in the Arabic language there are certain rules that go with the word sirat the first rule is that it can only be used for a straight path
Okay?
Serat, the word serat, it can only be used for a straight path.
If a road is bumpy, or if it curves, or if the road is wavy, it cannot be serat.
Right?
So by definition, the word serat, it means that the path has to be straight.
So the word serat, right, just with the
with the dumma at the top, surat, it is actually used for a perfectly straight sword.
That's a surat.
If the sword is curved, it is called saif.
You know some of these swords that we see in old movies?
So, Malana Ali's
sword Zulfiqar is a good example of that right it's we know that it's curved right the shape of Zulfiqar was curved so what what is that what did Rasulullah say?
La Fata illa aliyun, La Saifa illa Zulfiqar not La Swarata illa Zulfiqar right he said La Saifa illa Zulfiqar because Saif by definition is a curved sword right so Sirat means a perfectly straight path that's the first thing
The second rule is that Serat can only be used for a wide path.
By definition, Serat cannot be used for a narrow path.
It has to be a wide path.
A path that allows multiple people to travel on it simultaneously.
So in our world, just think of it like a major highway with multiple lanes.
except that it's just a perfectly straight highway.
You understand?
Now, this is something very cool.
There are other words in Arabic that can be used for a path.
There are various different ways.
So, for example, there is Sabeel, which means a path.
There is Faj, which means a path.
There is Fariq, which means a path.
Now, what's really interesting about these words is that there are plurals available for all these words.
So, for instance, for Sabeel, there is Subul.
Right?
The plural of Sabeel is Subul.
For Tariq, the plural is Tawariq.
For Faj, the plural is Fijaj.
What was really interesting is that there is no plural for the word Serat.
It is a singular word.
And this is why Sirat also means the only available path.
So imagine
Just imagine these two islands that are connected by a single bridge, right?
There is water under the bridge and the water between these two islands, it's very turbulent.
Think about it that way, right?
You cannot take a boat to go from one side to the other or one island to the other.
The only way for you to get from point A to point B in this case is this one single wide bridge.
There is absolutely no other path for you to take except this bridge.
You understand?
So in this case where there is no alternate route available, then that bridge, that one singular wide path would be called Serat.
So Serat linguistically has these peculiar characteristics.
It has to have, it has to be a wide path, it has to be a straight path, and it has to be the only path to that destination.
So now what does all of this mean for us?
It means that there can be many many paths available to us in terms of how we choose to live our lives.
There can be many religions, there can be many belief systems, all of which can be correct.
But the path that directly leads to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, it can only be one.
It means that even though there are many different religions, many different philosophies, all explaining how to reach God, all explaining how to live your life, the word serat indicates that there can only be one true religion, the perfect religion.
Think about it like that.
The perfect religion.
So there is good, there is
better, that is best, that is perfect.
If you start breaking it down in that way, Serat indicates the perfect religion.
Right?
It's a religion, a path that will be the shortest distance between point A and point B, connecting the slave to his master.
Now, if this was not interesting enough, which obviously it is,
what's what really blows my mind is that Allah did not just say sirat in this verse he said as-sirat right he used the definite article the this the path the particular path now sirat already meant one single path by its definition then why say as-sirat
because even though Islam is the one true religion there are many many sects within Islam and by making this word a definite by adding the definite article to serat making it a serat what is being taught here that there can only be one perfectly true sect within Islam itself isn't that incredible
So just by understanding the linguistics of the word, it can answer all of our questions, you know, because people ask this all the time.
I used to ask this question all the time, you know, why does there only have to be one true religion?
Why can't every religion be a true religion?
It can't because the word Sarah does not have a plural.
So it can only be singular.
It must be straight, which means it must take the shortest route to connect us with Allah.
Right, because the shortest distance between two points is a straight line.
Also, it must be a wide path, which means there has to be acceptance for others along the way.
That's firaat, but then as firaat means that there is only one sect, one lane that will, the fastest lane, right?
Think about it on a highway, you have the slow lane, you have the fast lane, so this is the fast lane that will directly lead to Allah using the shortest distance.
it's the most direct path to Allah subhanAllah all of these meanings are encapsulated in the single word as-sarat and this is not to say that the rest of Islam and all the other sects are all garbage no of course not it's all it means is that it's going to take them longer to get there but they will eventually get there everybody is going to eventually get there and
this is why all Muslims of all sects regardless right they pray for this knowledge of this direct path to Allah because all Muslims are praying in and saying including us I mean we just you know knowing the straight we so even if I say that is the is the is the fastest path is knowing that path and actually walking the path are two different things
so that is why we're also saying we're also constantly praying for for because if you think about it if we if we strongly believe we truly believe in our hearts that we are on the right path on the right we are the right sect within the the world of Islam then why do we have to constantly keep asking for this guidance why do we have to keep every prayer why do we have to keep saying we already are on the right path but
Being on the right path and walking the path are two completely different things.
Just by standing on the path, I do not get to my destination.
I have to walk the path, right?
So there's so many other nuances within this which I'm skipping over, but I've given you the basics and if you really think about it and if you really reflect on it, it'll open up so many more, it'll open up a world of understanding for you.
Anyway, so that is As-Sarat.
Now the word Mustaqeen, it is Ihdina as-Sarat al-Mustaqeen, right?
How is Mustaqeen translated generally?
Ihdina as-Sarat al-Mustaqeen guide us to the straight path.
But we already established that Serat, it already implies straight, right?
Because if it wasn't straight, it wouldn't be Serat.
So now why is Allah repeating Himself?
He's not.
Because mustaqeen does not just mean straight, it actually means upright.
The word mustaqeen, it comes from qama or istaqama, which means to stand up.
Not so much to go forward, but to go upward, right?
It's from qiyam.
which means to stand upright so in Salat in our prayers you know we have Paam we have Rukur we have Sujood right so what does Paam mean means to stand up straight that's what Paam is so when we say we are asking Allah for guidance on a path which heads which way straight up it is
We're asking guidance for a path of spiritual elevation.
Now think about this.
What happens when I travel on a path that puts me on an elevation?
The more I travel on it, the higher I will rise.
Isn't that true?
Imagine this.
path that is just a physical path.
Think of it as a ladder, like this ladder that is going from the ground all the way up to the sky.
As I'm climbing this ladder, what am I rising above?
I'm rising above this dunya, isn't it?
And as I rise higher, who am I getting close to?
I'm getting closer to Allah.
Now, what happens to the view as you rise higher?
It becomes better, it becomes broader, right?
You start getting a better perspective on things.
We already established that walking this path is all about gaining knowledge.
So the more we learn, the more knowledge we acquire, the more aware we become of the realities of this world and of the afterlife.
this path of spiritual elevation helps mold and form our perspective but then there's a negative side to this as well because the higher you climb the more danger there is of falling so if you are you know one foot high and you fall off from a stool you'll be okay right if you're 20 feet high and you fall you're not going to be so okay
If you're 100 feet high and you fall, right?
So in other words, the person who is traveling on this path for a long time, is he in less danger or is he in more danger?
He's in more danger.
And this is why you'll see that the higher the rank of the person, the more khushur this person shows in his salat, it just manifests.
the more because he has so much more fear in his heart the you know the more khushu he has the more he cries on his prayer mad during salat and this is why we find the sahaba exercising extreme caution at every single step of their way not because they love to be miserable which is the impression we get sometimes reading these books of sira I mean at least I used to think that way I'm like what is wrong with these people like why
Allah has not asked us to be miserable in life he has asked us to enjoy life and have lead a good life and all of that then why are these people suffering or putting themselves through these hardships of constant prayer constant fasting just right because Allah never demanded that yet we find if we read the books of seerah we find these people just striving to the nth degree and it never made sense to me until I understood the linguistics of this why did they do that
They did that because of this caution and this superior perspective.
You know, we look at them and we think that they are suffering.
But if we had a chance to ask them, they would say that they were enjoying it, they were loving it, because they were excited about their destination.
And so the work to get there no longer felt like work, you understand?
So if you have a goal, if there is something that you want to achieve and you're really crazy about achieving it, you're really motivated about getting there, the effort to get there is actually enjoyable.
You don't really care about it.
Think about a rocket.
A rocket that is headed towards space.
That's literally .
It is on a path that is directed upward.
Now, we know that this rocket, it needs a lot of fuel, it needs a lot of force, it needs a lot of energy to overcome the gravity of this Earth.
But once it breaks through the gravitational field and it enters space, there is no effort required for any kind of movement.
All it needs is a bit of thrust here and there, and it'll just glide to wherever it wants to go.
So that's what the Sahaba were aiming for.
That's why they put so much work, because then once they perfected it, once they rose above the perspective of this inferior dunya, once they became aware of the unlimited and infinite space, the infinite possibilities of the solar system, galaxies, this universe,
then this insignificant dunya became worthless to them.
So if you really grasp this concept, and if you start looking at it from this perspective, you know, you can really reconcile a lot of their behavior in this world.
So we say .
When we say it in Surah Al-Fateha, when we pray , what we're actually saying is
Grant us the gift the gift of guidance Grant us the gift of true knowledge through your book through the practical examples of your beloved and chosen people and Then as we begin our spiritual journey towards you following the footsteps of your chosen ones accompany us every single step of the way
Support us, assist us as we walk through this path that is straight, that is wide, and that is the only path that elevates us towards You.
Bring us into this fast lane.
Help us move along this fast lane.
Help us see things clearly as we rise above this dunya and move towards You.
and then protect us from falling back into this dunya.
This is the Aun, the assistance that we beg for daily in our five daily prayers.
Then we say, Siraat al-Ladina anaam ta'alaihim, the path of those whom You bestowed Your favors upon.
Now this what's interesting is that this verse it actually uses the past tense.
Right?
On the path of those on whom you bestowed your favours.
So why the past tense?
The reason is because all these role models they exist in the past.
So you know if you're a student and you want to get some good career advice
Who do you seek that advice from?
Do you seek it from your fellow students or do you seek that advice from graduates?
Obviously the graduates, right?
You're not going to ask your friend who is studying with you in the same school, in the same class about career advice.
So if you want to become a doctor, you'll take advice from graduate doctors, you know.
What course did you take?
How did you get into this program?
what are the things that I need to focus on so the verse says the path of those on whom you showered your blessings the path of the prophets the path of the messengers the path of the martyrs all these righteous people
right the word anamta actually comes from the root word ni'am which means something that is smooth and soft right this there's this word in Arabic for cattle you know cows and sheep in Arabic they're called anam because they walk very slowly they walk in a gentle manner
so this verse is identifying and specifying the path that was requested in the previous verse you know when we said oh Allah guide us on this path towards this path of spiritual elevation what is that path it is the path of those who were successful in reaching you those who got through the trials of this world in a soft and smooth manner
and achieved spiritual elevation.
That is .
Then we say .
Not on the path of those who received your wrath, your ghadab, who became the recipients of your anger and not on the path of those who are lost.
Now this is really interesting because
When the verse talked about blessings, right, when it talked about ni'amah, an-amta alaihim, the verse reads, sarat al-lazeena an-amta alaihim, the path on whom you showered your blessings, right?
But when it came to ghadab, Allah says, al-maghdoobi alaihim, the ones who receive the ghadab,
You see that?
It leaves out the subject.
It just says those who received your anger.
Not those that you were angry upon, but those who received your anger.
See, when I say he got beaten, the question that comes up is who did the beating?
It could be one, it could be many, right?
So what this is telling us is that those who receive Allah's anger, they're not just receiving Allah's anger, they're receiving the anger of messengers, the anger of angels, the anger of other believers, the anger of the heavens, the earth, right?
They're receiving the wrath and the anger from all directions.
And so this verse, it does not mention Allah when it talks about Ghadab.
but it specifically mentions Allah when it talks about blessings the ones you showered blessings upon but is not those who you became angry with because anger and ghadab was never the intention of Allah to begin with because he is a Rahman so whatever they did they did it to themselves
you see they earned it for themselves but the ones who received blessings Allah helped them along the way towards the right path you know with the help of instructions with the help of guidance through messengers through all of these intermediaries and then also by helping them along the way with his Huda with his with his knowledge so in other words it means on the path of those who you granted
blessings and what is that blessing we talked about this earlier that's knowledge so essentially this is saying on the path of those that whom you granted knowledge the knowledge of realities and then the ones whom you granted the examples of how to put that knowledge into action through role models like Rasulullah , through Mullan Ali, through the Imams, through the Duat and then that personal divine companionship along the way
all of that is encapsulated in sarat al-adhina an amta alayhim not on the path of those whom you gave knowledge but they chose not to act upon it and not on the path of those who act but they have no knowledge of what they're doing da'leen means the one who is lost
who does not know any better.
And notice that the word Sera'at is not used with Maghdoobi alayhim and it is not used with Daleen.
You see, it's only used with Anamta alayhim because that is the Sera'at al-Mustaqim, the one that has the blessings of Allah.
Now,
Let me try to explain this difference between Maghdoobi Ali Him and Daleen with a simple example.
So I have two children, right?
I have Iram and Amir.
Iram is 13, Amir is 7.
So, you know, they both love chocolate chip cookies, right?
So I buy a fresh box from the store and
you know, I give that box to Adam and I say, both of them, I put that box in front of both of them and I say, look guys, I know this is your favorite cookie and you know, can you see how nice this is and how fresh it looks right here, smell it, smell it, right?
So I put that in front of them and then I tell them, look, all of this stuff is so cool, but you cannot have them.
I'm going to place this right here on the table right in front of you.
And then I'm going to go downstairs in my basement to record this session on Fateha.
And when I come back, we will eat these together because I brought it for all of us to share together.
But until I return, don't touch these cookies.
I'm telling Eram this, right, because she's the older one.
And I'm also telling her, make sure Amir does not eat them as well because he's still a kid.
Right?
So I explain all of this to Eram and then I go in the basement, I do my session, right?
And then I come back upstairs and what do I find?
I find these two cookie monsters sitting on the couch, right?
They're both just wolfing all of these cookies down.
Now, who am I going to get mad at?
Eram or Amir?
Obviously Eram.
Why?
Because I explicitly, very clearly told her not to eat those cookies.
I did not tell Amir.
He doesn't know what's going on, right?
But I specifically told Adam not to eat the cookies.
So obviously, I'm going to be a lot more angry with her because, you know, she knew better.
I'll tell her that I'll say, I clearly told you not to eat these cookies and you still disobeyed me.
Right?
And while I'm shouting at her and scolding her, Amir is looking at me innocently and he's still like eating these cookies.
But you understand the difference, right?
The difference between Maghdoobi alayhim and Daalin is that the Maghdoob are the ones who were given the niyama of knowledge.
They were shown the right path and they still chose to disobey Allah.
They still chose to do the wrong thing.
But Daleen are the ones who had no clue that they were doing the wrong thing.
It doesn't mean that they're innocent.
It doesn't mean that they will not be taken to account.
Because Allah gave all of us intellects, right?
Which is a proof and a hujjah for and against each and every one of us.
Right?
It is a proof that we need to seek knowledge.
So, oh, I just didn't know is not a good enough excuse because that's what the intellect was given to you for, so that you would gain knowledge.
So the are the people who should have strived to gain the necessary knowledge of Allah and then do the right thing.
They should have made that effort to know better.
So they're not off the hook by any sense, but they're still better than .
which are the people who absolutely knew what the right thing to do was and they still chose not to do it.
So that's the difference between these two terms.
So this is the real message of Fateha, this balance between knowledge and action.
Right?
So, Bismillah, Rahman, Raheem, Alhamdulillah, Rabbil Alameena, Rahman, Raheem, Maliki, Aumidine.
These verses are all about knowledge.
These are all about seeking knowledge of our Master, getting to know Him, getting to understand Him, understand what He wants, why He created us, what does He want from us?
What's this concept of mastery?
What's this concept of slavery?
And what are the advantage of Ubudiya?
And how can we achieve freedom through this?
And this idea that we are the ones in need of him because he has something that he can give to us that we want rather than him wanting us to do something.
So that is all encapsulated in these verses.
And then we have .
This is our recognition and our acceptance of this knowledge being the one true knowledge.
you know and and us making a commitment to Allah and after that we have guide us to the only straight and wide path of knowledge that elevates us and brings us closer towards you right guide us to the path of Iman give us the ultimate gift of Iman through the path of Islam which is your
ultimate blessing this path that is this religion that is the perfect balance between knowledge and action so guide us along this path through the examples of role models of the people of the past that you have favored the ones who were wise who had wisdom you remember the definition of wisdom to have correct knowledge and then to act upon it
That's a wise person who has the knowledge and then acts upon it.
So make us among those people of these role models of the past that when they were provided knowledge they acted upon it.
Do not make us among those who gain knowledge but then do not act upon that knowledge.
Because those are the people who will receive your wrath from all directions on the day of judgment.
Because of the bad decisions that they made.
And do not make us from among those who act without knowledge.
Because they are the ones who are lost.
So the essence of Suratul Fateha is this balance between these two things.
It is balancing Ailm with Amal, knowledge with action.
It is, you know, balancing, it is the balance between gaining the knowledge of Allah, right, striving to acquire the knowledge of his Tawhid, making a commitment, this promise, this Ahid, which has to come before the action, and only after that comes the instructions, right, the Hidayah.
and then we ask Allah to make us among those who created this balance between knowledge and action and this is why Maulana Ali says knowledge without action is a calamity on the soul and action without knowledge is pure ignorance it's perversion so success
It lies in the middle.
It lies at the center of this balance between knowledge and action.
That is the true manifestation of Abhudiya.
A slave who obeys through knowledge, who strives to understand the wisdom of his master's commands and then practically acts upon it realizing that this is for his own benefit.
And that is the entire essence of Surah Al-Fatihah.
Wakharudawan an alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalam ala rasuli saidna Muhammadin Khatim in Nabin wassaid al Mustalin walaqi wa wassi alib nabi talek, asharafil wassiyin wa ilalayim matim zuriyatim mataibin al-tahirin wassalim alayhim majmain al-Fatihah